fatalement rejoignent il ya une clé à
gagner qui va peut-être nous faire
ouvrir une lourde en fin de semaine et
faire gagner beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
pour envoyer des enfants ce qui isabelle
morini bosc
on va avoir besoin de votre mémoire
jérémy a une excellente mémoire c'est
votre adversaire aujourd'hui on la
choisit pour sa mémoire
vous allez jouer avec nous essayer de
jouer également chez vous ça va être
très simple je vais soulever
ceci pendant 15 secondes finalement
ensuite vous devrez placer ce qui avant
premiers skis avant deuxième attaque
tacle à la fin je regarderai d'accord et
qu'il ya une erreur une erreur c'est
faldo et non légal un merci beaucoup et
lord égale père nous perdons dos
lorsqu'elle est belle celle ci ça sent
la boulette par ici ah oui mais je vais
en faire une
alors attention vous êtes prêt et oui
oui où mais attention
concentre-toi y voit deux à sarakhs de
ce côté on partira de la hague avait tué
en premier donc ces deux donc harry ça
vous dit harris a
harris a ici très bien à vous ensuite il
y avait quoi non je fais comme elle ou
chaleur intense du fidjien normalisée
qu'est ce qu'il y avait en deuxième a en
deuxième fois 2e
je remets une couche d'harissa donc
avait encore de larissa en 3e âge du
thon je crois je me suis je trompé donc
mais disons c'est quoi mais il ya vous
n'avez que deux tu nous as well as la
cave aux jeunes je remets une couche de
molex à oui c'est moi qui te laisse
souffler mais pourquoi alors parce
qu'elle avait dit à moi j'ai continué la
suite à la 10 je l'avais de m j'ai pas
mis à votre place elle a déclaré j'ai
dit que j'avais de moulay abdellah dhik
vallée dorée merci beaucoup
paulette boulette boulette houlette ton
genre dont vous faites n'importe quoi
maintenant c est vrai c penser mais
c'est peut-être mal pensé mais ses
pensées d'accord allait il nous reste
jérémy aller
allez ça bosse sont là dedans vous
l'êtes encore il en reste combien m 2 2
alors moi je mets celle du mou débat
doit bien faire ça je vais souffler bah
oui mais ça n'est pas le faire aller
ouais l'accord ton nom moyens non en
fait c'est plus court donc peut-être que
c'est je vous expliquerai quoi alors
attention vous avez dit harris a en
premier c'est c'est eh oh ce genre
d'outil sur ses tarifs la bonne réponse
attention
il sera ensuite pour jérémy et au
harissa attention vous avez dit on après
oui connaissez beaucoup de vous manger
beaucoup de ton nom j'aimerais adresser
un mail me shy'm au châble le couperet
j'aime les tons ton bravo isabelle si
c'est pas vous l'êtes vous faire des
jeunes
vous avez des boulettes egypte ces
boulettes
ces moules à tréboul est pas d attendait
venez ne revenez la tenez là ça suffit
après vous avez dit harris avoue oui je
me suis tombé pied pas sûr du tout sur
l'art is a way et je vais je me suis
trompé de reprendre au sénat
j'étais bon c'est du salat tac et ya
juste resalah vous avez mis n'arrive pas
de trop oui mme isabelle morini-bosc
malheureusement c'est perdu ma chérie
la clé va donc à la mer voilà c'est
perdu c'est celle d'ella maillart dick
quoi qu'est ce que ça veut dire quoi la
véridique
merci jérémy bravo il valoir
[Musique]